advice to a screenwriter working on
their first screenplay and thinking
they're going to sell it move to malibu
we had another guy in this chair that
would
always use the word malibu as like you
know sell it malibu
money comes but that that notion that
that first screenplay is going to be it
for them and watch them
for the first bit of advice that i have
is you're not going to sell it
a first script is a learning script um
i was i was teaching class yesterday and
i told the writers if you're pitching a
script that is your first script
don't ever say this is my first script
because the minute that we hear people
like me here this is my first script we
know this is your learning script
you're going to learn how to write on
your first second third script
by the fourth script you're going to get
kind of good by the fifth script you'll
really have a handle on your voice
so there is no selling that first script
i literally don't know
anybody literally who sold
their first script in recent years i
mean granted last night i interviewed
uh scott alexander and larry kurzowski
who wrote ed wood
larry flint man on the moon and they did
manage to sell their first script but
this was in
1980 something um and they and they said
in the room this is clearly not the way
that that it's done um so in
all likelihood odds are you're not going
to sell your first you got to love it
you got to put your heart into it
but you have to understand this is an
intellectual exercise and learning how
to write screenplays
you really do have to see it as your
training piece
so if you have five ideas and one you
love and it's the one that you think is
going to make you a million dollars
hold that back work on your skill before
you invested in it because oftentimes
i'll talk to my writers who are
newer writers and we'll talk about where
script is at and they will say to me i
think i brought it as far as i can bring
it
skill wise at this point i need to set
it aside
if i wanted to go further i need to
revisit it in a year two years when i've
worked on other stuff
which is the right the right assumption
what a writer should expect is that it's
going to take three to ten years to
break into the entertainment industry
that's what it takes this is what we see
day in and day out
it is hardly ever done in shorter spurts
i know somebody watching this will go
well i'm the one who's going to do it
and more power to you but
this is just the general expectations i
have both clients and friends who are
breaking in
all the time every day they're all
working at it for years
and that's okay this is what it takes
this is how it works
in all likelihood you're not selling
your first if your first can get you
some exposure
fantastic but we are in an industry
where right now we're in the beginning
of september we sold 43 specs
this year that's an abysmal number so
we're not selling a lot of product right
now it's gonna change we're gonna sell
more
but the likelihood of selling a script
in a market where roughly 80 000 scripts
are getting registered
a year with the wga and 41 or 43
are selling within eight nine months
not high you just have to run the
numbers it is a lottery
so save that passion project that
because i've heard a lot of people here
today
that want to write about something that
happened to them when they were younger
whatever and they're very close to the
material
maybe that one that they think is going
to to change everything that's very
personal to them
hold back on that you're saying work on
five or six others that
maybe aren't as perfect your script you
become a better writer this is a skill
based craft your skill gets stronger and
stronger and muscle gets stronger
and stronger the more you write so you
do have to keep writing and perfecting
your craft
in order to get to a place where you can
write those really hard to execute
scripts
you